I don't really like those words
self-help or self management or
self-improvement I don't really like
what those words have come to mean these
days because there's a lot of people out
there that are constantly trying to
improve themselves by looking for the
one change the one change right the one
change in their life that's gonna make
their dreams come true and even worse on
top of that there's a lot of people out
there a lot of self-help gurus and these
hyperactive motivational speakers and
these other self-appointed modern Zen
yoga warriors that they're trying to
sell the one thing they're trying to
sell the nine steps or the enlightened
path that's gonna allow you to unlock
all of your human potential and fulfill
the dreams so you can live the life that
you've you've always wanted to live
now I'm no guru and I definitely don't
claim to be I'm just a man but I will
tell you this it isn't one thing and it
isn't ten things and it isn't a hundred
things it isn't a quick path and there
are no shortcuts the meditation won't
get you there and neither will a miracle
drug or an organic supplement or some
superfood getting better isn't a hack or
a trick or one change that you need to
make getting better is a campaign it's a
campaign it's a daily a weekly it's an
hourly fight an incessant fight that
doesn't stop against weakness and
against temptation and against laziness
it's a campaign of discipline the
campaign of hard work and dedication
it's waking up early and going to bed
late and grinding out every second
between every single day so you want to
get better you want to self-improve stop
looking for a shortcut and go find your
alarm clock and find your discipline and
fling your guts and your passion and
your drive and find that you will and
then and then you will find your freedom